okay
okay good um yeah my presentation will
actually in some way continue um
pascal's presentation and also pick up
some of the points we were discussing
yesterday you know how can we
distill real
understanding about mechanisms from the
big data so how can we go beyond just
making good predictions
and also linking genotype to phenotype
this big question
so the question that i will address here
is um what determines whether a genetic
variant has an effect in the molecular
network that is confined to small part
of the network as opposed to affecting
large parts of the network you know
having these long-range effects in
molecular networks
so what determines whether effects are
local or global
i will also talk very briefly about a
paper that we just published but because
it's published this part will be very
brief so you can read the paper
okay so what we want to know is you know
how do genetic variants impact cellular
traits
and
uh for this we are looking at a
molecular networks because they actually
mediate these effects
um so we do eqt protein qtl and other
qtl studies
most people are looking at
concentrations of molecules
concentrations of transcripts proteins
and small molecules how are they
affected
by genetic variants and then they do the
qtl studies
we've just published a work where we're
looking at states of proteins and i
think this is really the next level we
have to go beyond concentrations we also
have to look at states of molecules so
in this published paper we have done the
very first phospho qtl study phosphor
proteome qdl study
um so this is the the paper uh it came
out i think like eight weeks ago or
something
um and just briefly the study because
the data is actually relevant also for
what i'm going to show afterwards the
unpublished work
um so this is based on a cross of two
yeast strains rm and by we didn't do
this this was done by lynnette krugliak
and rachel brown many years ago so this
is a very well characterized population
of
genetically heterogeneous yeast strains
and this is great because there's a lot
of background knowledge that we can
utilize for the interpretation of the
data so we have this cross
and then we
took cultures from these cells and
subjected them to rna sequencing uh
protein quantifications or swath
proteomics or dra proteomics and then
the phosphor data so this was the
innovative part
and i think it was really important that
we had all three um
layers omix layers from identical
cultures which really increases the
ability to compare the data between
these different layers
important to know is that
the protein concentrations will be
correlated with the mrna concentrations
um so this is what you see here so
there's a lot of positive correlation
between proteins and their encoding rnas
encoding mrnas
um but there's also correlation between
phosphopeptides and the proteins of
which they are part
um so this
kind of is it's trivial right if mrna
goes up the protein will also go up so
we wanted to distinguish effects that
are mediated through the mrna at the
protein level from the effects that are
directly targeting the protein for
instance through modulating translation
of the protein or protein stability so
those effects would be independent of
the mrna
so this is these are things we want to
distinguish and the same is true for the
phospho effects because um if a protein
is upregulated then the phosphopeptide
or the residue of the phosphoaminol
phosphorylated amino acid will also go
up that's kind of trivial so we want to
distinguish effects of for instance
kinases modulating phosphorylation of
the target protein from effects that are
just due to abundance changes of the
protein
um so the the way how we did this was uh
relatively simple we just did regression
so we regressed the uh phosphor level of
um
sorry the level of a phosphopeptide as a
function of its uh protein which is part
so here each each dot would be
one strain
and we're always looking at the same
phosphopeptide
across these different strains and then
we're doing a linear regression
and then we're saying this is the
variance of the phosphopeptide that is
explained by protein level variation and
then we regress out this effect in order
to
focus on effects that are independent of
the protein abundance so we're looking
at the residuals residuals are
noise to some extent and to the other
extent it's a variation in
phosphorylation that is independent of
protein abundance
we did the same with the protein rna
relationship so we again regress protein
levels as function of the mrnas
and then we do the same trick so um we
say that this is the variance that is
explained by the mrna and the remaining
variation the residuals are due to
post translational effects
or post-transcription effects
or noise of course
so we create new traits so now we have
we have the mrna level as a trait we can
map we have the protein level as a trait
we can map but we can also map these
residuals as new molecular traits that
are derived from the other molecular or
mixed layers
we can now ask which genetic variants
are affecting these residuals
so this is what we did we did this
regression and now we have
five omix layers that we can map as
molecular traits to to the genome we
have the mrna we have the protein
abundance we have those residuals as an
intermediate layer we have the
phosphopeptides and again the residuals
as an intermediate layer
the way how we do a qtl mapping is using
machine learning so we use like to use
random forest
this has advantages compared to the
linear methods which are more frequently
used because random forest returns for
nonlinear effects it accounts for
interactions between different loci so
we've shown in the past that it actually
is more powerful than
linear qtl mapping methods
um we have many uh papers on this it's
we like it because it's very intuitive
it's very robust so there's no tuning
that you have to do
uh you can easily paralyze it because
it's based on training trees so each
tree can be trained on one node if you
want
it accounts as i said for the static
effects and you can also explain it to
an audience without showing any
equations which is not relevant in this
audience but in other audiences it does
matter
okay so here are the papers we've
published on this uh if you if you're
interested in this approach
so now some data i have only two slides
on this because as i said it's published
so first is how um
are genetic effects that change mrna
levels mediated to the protein level
and essentially it's a one-to-one
relationship and this is not trivial so
what you see is the
allelic effect on protein levels and
then the allelic effect on the encoding
mrnas
and if you regress through all proteins
you get uh almost a slope of one so this
is a perfect uh correlation but not a
perfect correlation but but it's like a
like a perfect
transmission of the effects from mrnas
to proteins and that disagrees with
earlier work and i think this is mostly
because earlier studies didn't have the
same sensitivity at the proteome level
so they were biased for high abundance
proteins which are mostly ribosomal
proteins
and because now the technologies are
much more sensitive we have a less
biased view of the proteome and i think
now we see the truth which is that most
of the effects are directly transmitted
to the protein level so these are the
ones in gray but we do have some
exceptions we have the the green
proteins here this is very interesting
these are in effects that are enhanced
at the protein layer so they are
stronger than expected based on the mrna
and then we have the purple ones which
are buffered
effects
so this mostly so these buffered effects
where the effect on the protein is
weaker than on the mrna it's mostly due
to stoichiometric control so if you over
express a protein but the protein is not
included for instance in a ribosome if
it's a ribosomal protein it will be
degraded so that is buffering this over
expression effect
the second or one second important
finding there more is that
the phosphor layer really helps in
interpretation of cellular traits so
we've looked at hundreds and hundreds of
different cellular traits of compound
resistance and morphological traits
and it turns out that the
phosphor levels explain the variation of
those traits much better than protein
levels the greenest protein levels or
mrna the blue
so it really is important to look
at protein states and especially the
signaling this is what the phosphor
layer really represents the signaling
that's going on in the cell
okay now the new work so now we want to
map network states so essentially we
want to
view the state of a molecular network as
a trait that you can map
so you can say okay this variant is
modulating this network state
in particular we're interested in the
question
of the difference between long-range
effects and local effects so long-range
effect would be an effect that is
modulating large parts of the network
and then eventually changing some
cellular trait
and those are mostly also pliotropic
effects so this is the link to pascal's
presentation
while local effects
are usually much more specific they only
affect a small number of traits if maybe
just one
so what distinguishes these two types of
effects
so the the question is what are genetic
effects propagating through large parts
of the molecular network
as opposed to when they are confined to
small parts of the network so local
versus global
my conception of this is that um if you
if you look at this very high
dimensional space that is created by
the molecular traits we can quantify so
all the transcript levels or the protein
levels this would create a you know 20
000 dimensional space in yeast not that
many
um then
many combinations of traits in this
space are inviable so they're not
possible so the cell would just die if
you would have a specific combination so
this means that only a very small
subspace of all possible trait
combinations creates a viable cell
and then out of those most are actually
in favor through evolution because they
are not fit they are viable but they are
not fit so there is selection against
those combinations of traits
so that further reduces the space of um
let's say observable
combinations of molecular traits that
you find when you're looking at
natural genetic variation
so if you want you could say that this
is kind of a manifold you know in this
high dimensional space and the network
is essentially moving on this manifold
when you have genetic variation i think
that with if you do knockouts you could
easily push this the cell out of this
this manifold so this is a problem with
knockouts that sometimes they create
a state that is
to which the cell is not adapted and
then you get a non-physiological
response but here we're looking at
natural genetic variation so
most of the allele combinations happen
in nature as well so there's no at least
no strong selection against them so this
is the space on which the network is
moving
so if you know this is our space then
the green dots would be observed states
we have in our cross in this particular
cross and then the yellow ones would be
states that you may observe if you
created new allele combinations that's
the idea here
um
so
this this is an important notion because
that means that if you change some part
of the network other parts of the
network he'll have to adapt
so you know you have to respond these
are the long-range responses of the
network
uh so for instance a very well-known
example in indies is that if you change
glycolysis if you don't regulate
glycolysis oxidative phosphorylation
will go up and if you reduce oxidative
phosphorylation glycolysis will go up
so you know there's this balance between
these two processes
and so what i'm saying here is that
there are different levels of
stoichiometry in the cell we have
stoichiometric control at the level of
protein complexes this was what i was
showing before if you have a protein
change it's buffered yeah you have
stoichiometric
constraints within one module so if you
have a specific metabolic pathway this
is where the term actually comes from
stoichiometry and then what we are
saying is that you also have stock
geometry at a much higher level between
those modules so this would be the
example you know we have two modules one
module controlling oxidative
phosphorylation another one doing
glycolysis and they're also coupled
and the the claim here is that there are
many many more processes in the cell or
modules whatever you want to call them
that are all coupled to each other
so this is what i'm trying to sell we
have already have an example of this um
published two years ago together with
your bella uh on pyruvate kinase one in
fission yeast um there's a
mutation or variant in the lab strain
that was used in the community for for
many many years and nobody noticed that
this variant is actually changing the
efficiency of oxidative phosphorylation
and so these cells were always turning
on glycolysis to a small extent well if
you had other wild-type strains they
would only do or much more to oxidative
phosphorylation
and then this is affecting many other
cellular traits
um like also growth and stress
resistance which will be important so
this is an example of those those mod
these modules and the connections
between them
um so this this is what my postdoc was
doing matthias white everything that i'm
showing now is from matthias um he was
interested in better understanding a
complex trait and
he chose heat stress so he did heat
stress experiments on this collection of
yeast strains
and then he quantified the trait which
is what he calls heat induced lag which
is just the lag time that the cells need
in order to recover from the heat stress
so it's a non-lethal
low level stress the cells survive and
then they they recover but they recover
at different speed
and that's the trait so the variation
here this is between the two parental
strains
this this is what he's quantifying as
his trait and now we want to know what
are the molecular determinants of this
variation of this complex trait
so first you can do just traditional qtl
mapping this is relatively boring
but straightforward so he identified the
three qtrs one two three that all
significantly correlate with the trait
so here on this on the y axis you have
the trait and then here you have the two
alleles either the b y allele or the rm
allele and you can notice that uh for
two of the qtls if you have the rm
allele
the
lag time is larger and on the third qtl
it's reversed so now the lag time is
shorter
so there's some kind of balancing of
alleles in the current restraints to
keep in both parent restraints this
stress response at some physiologically
favorable level
this is also called transgressive
segregation
now at the next step he wanted to
understand what are really the molecular
connections between the
loci here and the high level trait here
so what is connecting this
so he looked at protein levels this is
the same data that i showed before which
is already published
and he was just asking
which proteins explain the cellular
trait
again using random forest in this case i
guess a linear model would also do it's
not so important
but anyway so these are the proteins
that significantly explain the cellular
trait
and these proteins so this is the
correlation with the cellular trait but
these proteins are also affected by
genetic variants and especially they are
affected by these three qtls so here we
have the three qto one two and three
whenever you have an asterisk there's a
significant
linkage so this is a significant qtl
but you can see um here as well but you
can see that there's a very consistent
response which is not significant on the
level of individual proteins but if you
look at the set of proteins you can
clearly see that there's a response
now we have two types of qtls which is
very interesting so we have one this is
what i would call a local effect so here
this is a locus containing hsp104 this
is a cisqdo that is exclusively
affecting this one protein
and because it's a heat shock protein
it's obviously related to the heat
stress trait so this makes a lot of
sense so this is a local effect it's not
affecting anything else
and then you have these long-range or
global effects that are affecting
large parts of the molecular network
and especially this was very interesting
this cluster of proteins here the red
cluster it's marked in red
because all these proteins show a
consistent response so here in if you
have the rm allele they are up regulated
and here if you have the rm earlier they
are downregulated
so this again correlates with you know
these balancing effects
so then mathias
started to look into these proteins
asking what they are doing and it turns
out that they are all involved in
pka and tor signaling or that they're
targets of pka tour signaling
and that they are targeted by well-known
locals which contains the
rr2 protein so this is a well-studied
locus in this cross
and it's already known that this variant
here at the ir2 locus is affecting a
very large diversity of many cell
electrodes
um so basically what we're looking at
here is the
pka and tor signaling in yeast which is
converting on a common set of
transcription factors and genes which
are then controlled by these two
pathways
i'm also using the p word no i don't
like it
um but anyways so and
one thing is it's this these pathways
are also controlling the balance between
oxidative phosphorylation and
fermentation or glycolysis
so again this story comes back
so then matthias wanted to quantify the
activity of these pathways
because they converge we can't really
distinguish when you look at the levels
of proteins you can't really distinguish
the activities of these two pathways so
what he developed is an integrated score
that is
quantifying the combined activity of the
signaling pathway so pka and tor
and he did this by using
direct perturbations
of these two molecules pka and so this
is a pka inhibition this is for
inhibition
data and then he identified proteins
these are the marker proteins in green
and in blue that are strongly associated
with the activities of these two
pathways
so this is the effect of this rr2 locus
on these proteins and this is the effect
when you inhibit pka or when you inhibit
tor and you can see i hope it's quite
easy to see that there's a very strong
correlation which is just saying nothing
else but that rr2 controls you know this
pathway
so then he was picking these these
colored proteins as markers
so that he could in the future quantify
the activity of pkn towards signaling in
any cell in any strain any condition
so now we have a pt score pka and tor
score this is the pt score which i will
use in the remaining presentation
and
this is i think the most important slide
of my presentation because the amazing
observation is that this pt score
it's one
value
a one dimensional value this one value
correlates very strongly with large
parts of the molecular variation in this
cross
so here we have a pca of the
transcriptome data pca of the proteome
data pca of the phosphor proteome and
this is a pca of the residuals when you
regress out the protein abundance effect
and in all four cases you have a very
strong correlation between the pt score
and the
positioning of the strains in these pcas
so each dot is one strain and then it's
positioned based on the respective
molecule information and the coloring
reflects the pt score
and here you see uh you know the the
first pc the first principal component
very strongly correlates with the pt
score here also first component and here
first component correlate very strongly
with the pt score
and here it's the second component that
very strongly correlates with the pt
score
so that means that you know the
a major part of the variation that we
have can be
projected if you want or reduce down to
this one single value
so this essentially characterizes the
state of the network this was budding
yeast we also have new data in fission
yeast this is unpublished data
from fish and yeast within collaboration
with your baylor and we see the same
thing we have different conditions
unstressed and oxidative stress
and again we see a very strong
correlation with the pt score
in stress and non-stress conditions and
maybe it's not unexpected under the
stress condition the correlation is even
stronger here
coming back to the heat stress we also
have a very strong correlation between
the heat stress on this axis and the pt
score on this axis
and this correlation here is stronger
than using any of the qdls including the
rr2 locals which was the strongest udl
effect
that shows that this pt score really
integrates the effects of many different
loci
and therefore reflects also you know an
integration of this complex genetic
interactions
here the mark strains are the parents
the parent restraints they don't this is
this buffering you know they're always
in the center
yes yeah for me
it looks like it's setting only an upper
bound right it's because i mean
the bottom left or bottom right corner i
mean you have very high pt scores and
still
a short lag whereas
the the upper right corner is completely
blank so there's a correlation but it's
kind of
yes but i don't know to what extent
that's just noise
real biology
i mean there's still some variation here
along this axis
and um i mean this may be just an
outlier strain
but it might also be a real biology i
don't know we have to look into this
condition on that in order to get the
genetic variation that analyze
the studies
yes i think we did not do that
but what we did is so that i'm not
showing that but what we did do is we
regressed out the rf2 effect for
instance and then we still have strong
effects from the pt score which is
showing that it's really affected by
more than just one cost so it's really a
context rate that's data that i'm i'm
not showing because of time reasons
okay so the technical message here is so
one was the molecular state is majorly
determined by the pt score the heat
induced
time is also determined by the pt score
and now we come to the the take-home
message which is which is this balancing
between different modules that's going
on in the cell so explaining really
these long-range effects
so here each circle is a go term for if
you wish a module in the cell a
functional module
and on this axis you have how much does
this module
correlate how much through the protein
levels here's proteome protein levels of
this module correlate with the pt score
so you can have positive zero you can
have positive correlation or negative
correlation with the pt score and this
is the y-axis is basically the
significance
so here on the right-hand side positive
correlation with strong tors signaling
pka signaling is proliferation cells are
dividing they're growing like crazy so
here you have
all the terms that are related to
translation
and on the left-hand side when the
signaling is repressed you have all the
stress responses that are going on here
so here you have oxidative stress um
and also the heat stress
so this explains
the heat stress response but you also i
hope you can see that there are many
many cellular
functions that are correlated with the
pg score so this is this global
rearrangement of the cellular metabolism
that's going on when you fiddle around
with the pk and tor signaling
and they're all connected
so now the the claim that we have is
that when you change one of those
modules here through some genetic
variant that will have indirect effects
on the other modules because they have
to respond
this is really what's going on here and
that explains these long range effects
um these are just the other omics layers
um here we have the phosphor and the
phosphor residuals and this is very
interesting because we see now new terms
especially when you look at the phosphor
residuals here on the right hand side we
see for instance cell cycle
which is
majorly regulated through
phosphorylation signaling much more than
abundance changes so this makes a lot of
sense but here we now also see a
chromatin organization
um histone modification so you know
epigenetic
or modules which are related to
epigenetic control it's a very wide
range of cellular functions that are
affected by pt signaling
so this is the the model that we now
have we have local effects local effects
are genetic variants that change only
one protein or a very small set of
proteins
then we have regional effects where you
have
a pathway or a module so maybe this is a
some regulator a kinase or a
transcription transcription factor some
signaling molecule and then all the
molecules that are dependent on the
signaling molecule will change so this
would be a regional effect
but if this change would change the
activity of an important cellular module
that would have long-range effects so
these are the global effects which we
have here so you change one
module here let's say glycolysis
and then oxidative phosphorylation will
respond so then you have these more
long-range effects
and this
is very consistent i think with pascal
what you were just showing that there
are a lot of there's a lot of crosstalk
going on between these modules they're
not isolated
just to nail the story
now there's some some network analysis
and the last data slide
here we look at different hot spots so
hot spots are loci in the yeast genome
which are affecting large numbers of
molecular traits and this protein
concentration in this case
and then we correlate the effect um
with the change of the pt signaling
so here's the rr2 locus and you have a
very strong correlation with the pt
signaling in this case as we already
know so this is a locus that is heavily
changing the pka and towards signaling
bolt2 is
has a negative correlation and then we
also looked at the third example which
is this locus containing zap one where
we have a very weak or even no change in
pt signaling to distinguish different
types of responses
and this would be a local or regional
effect sorry not a local but the
regional effects would still hotspot is
affecting many molecules but this has
much fewer effects on other modules
and to show this in a quantitative way
we did some network analysis so we
looked at the distances of these target
genes in the network so how closely are
they connected in the target network
and this is the average distance or the
the pairwise distances of the target
molecules for these three loci and then
i hope you appreciate that for that one
we have relatively short distances here
this is two and three so they have short
distances while the other two low sides
have longer distances so you have a lot
lower fraction of target genes here but
you have many more targets with long
distances so here i don't know if you
can see it in the back but there's still
dots here
uh so up to a distance of eight which
doesn't exist for that one so that means
that the z1 targets are much more
compact in the network than targets of
rr2 and bo2
okay so long-range network effects are
mediated via modulating the balance
between cellular processes
the pka tor signaling league experience
variation of molecular traits at least
in this cross but we also have data
which again i couldn't show because of
time in fission yeast
uh that confirms i mean i was showing
one slide but we have a lot more data
and this this was amazing that this this
signaling this network state can be
reduced to a single score to just a
scalar
um and i think this has very strong
implications for animals
um i think you all know the vabrock
effect which is also changing this
balance between glycolysis and oxidative
phosphorylation
this is also very important during
development so when cells go from an esl
cell stage to later differentiation
states the the balance between
glycolysis and oxidative phosphorylation
is changing as well but this also has
major impacts on the general
organization of the cells during
differentiation
um
obviously this has impact on stress
resistance so the importance of tor
signaling
is well known also in animals
i'm involved in many studies looking at
aging and for instance suppression of
mtor signaling insulin signaling is very
well known to extend life span
and we have now also evidence that
there's uh the genetic variants in the
human population which target these
exactly same pathways the follicles
pathways in any in humans
and also extend lifespan in humans
okay acknowledgement um
these are the three people most mostly
involved in the studies that i was
showing matthias is the one who did all
the the new new work
uh our collaborators um rudy ever
soldiered baylor paula picardi they are
the ones that contributed to the work i
was showing today and funding
and i thank you for listening
it's more like sort of the relationship
between the pka signaling and just sort
of the way that we do experiments in
just uh serial passaging things like
that i don't know if you saw but we when
we were we were mapping suppressors of
various deletion alleles and ts alleles
and yeast using sga just to find linkage
groups and you could map the suppressors
and a very high percentage of the time
we saw passenger mutations which were
loss of function mutations in ira ii
lead to anything that negatively
regulates pka signaling and the reason
we think from doing experiments is
because
when you have mutations in those
negative regulators of pta signaling you
do a couple more divisions before
so you just become overrepresented in
the population
yes yeah they're very interesting
effects we really have to think about
this twice always you know because if
you have these fantastic mutations they
consume a glucose much slower than the
fast foreign cells and then when you
have them in culture you really have to
you know pay attention to these effects
absolutely yeah
okay thanks
oh